hey guys it's me Gary Vee having made a
video for calm in a while so it's good
to do so late night here in the office
hustling which is kind of ironic cuz
that's what I want to talk about article
today written in ink what that says why
Gary Vaynerchuk is flat-out wrong
Steve zoom in here get it clear get it
right um Michael Shai wrote this article
and you know first let me say this I
actually read it very carefully and I
think Michael's a good thing I don't
think he was looking at really drill me
I think he said some nice complimentary
things and actually ironically I fully
agree with this mean basic gist of that
you know I rely on brute force I'm a
one-man show and I create bottlenecks
and my approach is not scalable
um and the alternative is building
infrastructure and he's been tweeting a
lot and he's been referencing you know
Jason freed one of my dearest friends
who wrote a book free work and 37signals
and built a platform and I just wanted
to dress this because I thought I could
bring a lot of value to a lot of people
plus I wanted their dresses could be
were asking me I would respond um you
know first and foremost he references
the wine business and other things in
that nature I think he's really looking
at just one chest right if you would
really understand I do work hard
oh do respect to uh is actually
respectful thing to say um shine go talk
to Jason freed about how hard he worked
for ten fifteen first years of his
career he built a platform called thirty
seven Suzy but being built a business
and he's created a lot of efficiencies
and then there's some jargon about like
you really want to live on a he'll me
here my wrong be on a be on an island
Fiji and make money and that's great too
you know I can do that too by the way
Riley and I think there's a couple
things that I want to go someone first
of all there's so many ways to play the
game right you know I believe so much of
people that believe in efficiencies and
building structure and infrastructure
and letting business come to them I have
no interest in creating a bottleneck
shiny I think you're extremely naive if
you think I've created a bottleneck when
you have a 300 person company you know
yeah my name is of ADD or the wine
business yeah like that's my business
billing these things are making dollars
not to mention that when you build
infrastructure or you build personal
brand equity or you hustle yourself
opportunities happen my investments in
Twitter and Tumblr and things of that
nature that I've made a lot of money on
you know they happen because of my sheer
brute force created a platform about
community I really do think you're
looking at one chessmen you start
playing out the second just move the
book side ran once coming on a week
pretty order now those kind of things
you know somebody just bought a copy of
crush it oh so well somebody just bought
about a line on white lever calm boom I
don't think a bottlenecking friend and
so what I think is happening here is
there's a disconnect and what can happen
years down the line versus what can't
listen I'm a workaholic and I love the
hustle I love people I love working I
love being a bottleneck I love working
do you understand I like building
businesses and thus I still do it
I could have retired on a beach in Fiji
a long time ago and everybody coulda
said look how efficient and smart
he was it's just not what drives me just
like for some people building the
business doesn't drive them what drives
them is to get to that Fiji Island one
day and just chill on the beach and God
bless them there are so many ways to win
the business life but I think it would
be massively naive that when you use
examples of people like Jason freed not
to understand listen really carefully
Jason free worked his ass off to create
the opportunity to become
unless you're inheriting a crapload of
cash you have to work hard for the
opportunity to create infrastructure
I've got more infrastructure than you
think
friend